[Musique]
un fond intox est avec vous Antoine
fenaud bonjour bonjour Raphaël au menu
ce soir à une fausse information qui
touche l'ambassadeur de France en
Ukraine absolument c'est la Fox du jour
et vous allez vous allez l'apercevoir
une toute part en réalité de ce tweet
que vous allez voir juste ici il émane
de Jean-Michel cadenas vous le voyez
juste ici Jean-Michel cadenas c'est un
délégué départemental du rassemblement
national en Mayenne mais également été
battu au précédentes législatives et
voici ce qui relais notamment cette
citation c'est ça qui va nous intéresser
ici nous ne savons il dit l'ambassadeur
de France en Ukraine Étienne de
pont-saint démissionne avec cette
citation nous ne savons pas ce que nous
défendons ici même volo des mirzelinski
n'est plus ici à Kiev et Étienne de
Poncin qui lui répond il s'agit d'une
fake news merci de la retirer
immédiatement ça c'est pour l'effet nous
ce qui nous a intéressé ici un fond
intox c'est un peu de remonter le fil de
remonter la pelote de cette infox de
voir d'où part exactement cette citation
et bien cette citation on la retrouve
notamment sur plusieurs comptes elle a
été virale notamment sur des comptes
panafricanistes et vous le voyez juste
ici et vous on retrouve vous le voyez
Raphaël la même citation nous ne savons
pas ce que nous défendons en Ukraine
alors que zellenski lui-même n'est plus
en Ukraine l'ambassadeur en Ukraine
Étienne de Poncin démissionne donc voici
pour le contexte Raphaël et vous avez
remonté donc la piste de cette assertion
absolument on a remonté on l'appelote de
laine comme je vous le je vous le disais
et on ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
retrouve plusieurs publications plus ou
moins virales avec exactement la même
citation pour le pour se faire et bien
on a utilisé un moteur de recherche que
nous permettent les les réseaux sociaux
que je vous présente ici qui s'appelle
qui est un outil de Facebook qui
s'appelle woops Watt vous pouvez
rechercher ici avec une date notamment
je voulais je vous montre pour
information est-ce que retrouver un
poste particulier donc on est retombé
sur des publications notamment comme
celle-ci avec toujours
ça a commencé toujours de la même
manière lu quelque part très très urgent
avec notamment la même citation qu'on
retrouve ici nous ne savons plus que
nous défendons ici même volodi
mirzelinski notez bien Zelensky avec un
Z minuscule car vous allez le voir c'est
un fox a été reprise à plusieurs
reprises exactement sous la même forme
c'est aussi le cas notamment dans
celle-ci avec une illustration qui n'a
absolument aucun rapport on voit ici des
chasseurs F16 américains et toujours la
même citation vous le voyez ici cette
démission d'Étienne de Poncin avec cette
citation nous ne savons plus ce que nous
défendons ici et même volody mirzelinski
encore une fois avec le petit Z n'est
plus n'est plus ici à Kiev on l'a
également retrouvé alors il faut être
prudent également avec cette cette
affirmation sur le compte RT Afrique
alors on ne sait pas exactement ici on
n'a pas pu vérifier nos enfants intox
que RT Afrique dépendait bien du du
média de tenu par par l'État russe mais
voici encore la même la même affirmation
la démission donc de l'ambassadeur
contiennent de Poncin vous l'avez
compris Raphaël le fameux de l'histoire
alors le fin mot de l'histoire on y
vient c'est ça qui est intéressant la
publication originale part en fait de
cet article de d'un média sénégalais
sénénews qui a depuis été modifié pour
mieux coller avec l'actualité vous
essayez ici l'article modifié donc et la
le poste original si l'on peut dire
c'est celui-ci il pas il est issu d'un
page Facebook qui s'appelle observatoire
démocratique africain qui pourtant ne
partage pas d'ordinaire des propos ou
des théories plutôt complotistes et on
retrouve ici vous le voyez nous ne
savons plus ce que nous défendons ici en
Ukraine etc vous voyez encore une fois
la même affirmation nous un fois intox
on a essayé de contacter le
propriétaire de cette page et il faut
dire que c'est le dialogue a été plutôt
difficile avec lui on peut dire qu'on
est tombé tout simplement purement et
simplement sur un troll il faut bien le
dire un troll un troll numérique qui se
faisait un malin plaisir de ne pas
répondre à nos questions la formation
elle a en tout cas a été relayée
également vous le voyez ici par un
complotiste notoire s'il va nous trop
tard et elle serait basée notamment sur
cette interview de nos confrères de BFM
que l'ambassadeur Étienne de Poncin donc
accordé à nos confrères de BFM avec où
il affirmait qu'il avait passé notamment
vous le voyez c'était le 11 octobre
l'après-midi dans sa cave suite à un
bombardement vous le voyez c'est de là
que par toute l'infox et pour être tout
à fait complaire Raphaël sachez que
évidemment le Quai d'Orsay lui a
totalement démenti cette démission ils
l'ont d'ailleurs conforme confirmé à il
a d'ailleurs confirmé à nos confrères du
monde voici il n'a jamais été question
d'une démission l'ambassadeur et donc au
travail à quai voilà donc ce qu'on
pouvait dire pour quand on remonte un
petit peu le fil d'une infox mon cher
Raphaël merci mon cher Antoine c'était
un faux intox avec Antoine fenaud rester
avec nous on se retrouve dans 4 minutes
dans pour une nouvelle édition dans
Paris direct
[Musique]